hi my name is Jenn Penton and my film
love on the run has just released on VOD
+ digital and i am here to talk to you
about my five top tips for starring in
your first feature film forum major
project number one is on your leadership
something amazing has happened and you
at the tier that you're at have rocked
your audition and your callback and you
are now cast as a lead perhaps opposite
names in the industry who really respect
to have an immense body of work behind
them now is the time for you to really
step into the actor that you've always
known you could be and the actor that
you've certainly always wanted to be and
allow yourself to be the star of the
project there's an immense amount of
good responsibility that comes with that
that comes with being number one on your
call sheet as it were so be ready to
bring you're all ready to bring your
energy your your vibrance your presence
to every meeting every rehearsal and
certainly every day on set because you
are about to rock your film or your
Ranger project tip number two for you is
self care I cannot tell you how
important self care is going to be when
you're about to spend a couple weeks to
a month on set for a really big
important role so for me that looked
like I was on set we were on location
upstate New York and every day after
shooting we'd wrap it like 10pm and the
whole crew would go around a bonfire and
do a sing-along and it was amazing it
was like movie camp I'm so fun but I did
tear myself away from the bonfire every
night to go to bed by like 11 o'clock
Leigh doesn't and get a full night's
sleep so I could show up rested I drank
a ton of water I didn't have any alcohol
or anything like that and I was really
taking care of myself I was making sure
that I was journaling and
meditating and like anything that really
keeps you operating at your highest
vibration very very important to really
keep it up because self-sabotage can
sneak in at the moments we don't expect
and it can really undermine your up
leveling to something that you really
really want so don't let it get the best
of you stay on top of yourself tip
number three for starring in your first
major project is to be ready to learn
you're about to probably be on set for
the longest amount of time you ever have
and you're probably about to be in
virtually every scene so you're going to
have so many opportunities to not only
learn from your co-stars who are
probably bigger names who probably have
an immense body of work behind them and
have been able to show up as series
regulars on TV as stars in major studio
feature films you're going to have the
opportunity to work in a scene with them
and learn from their techniques how the
wide differs from the clothes how one
take differs from another are you
offering the same choice are you
offering different choices matching your
performance in a wide and a close or two
shot all of these are skilled we maybe
have it learned in our scene study
classes so you're going to have so many
opportunities to learn from your
co-stars and pick that up and have these
little gems of information you're also
going to learn from the crew we're in an
age of self producing or at your
fingertips than ever so if you have
stories to tell but you don't know how
to do it because that with your crew and
really paying attention to who does what
and how they make these things happen
and how many camera setups happen and
how consistent they are and the order in
which you shoot all of that whether you
learned it on your own or not previously
if you went to film school let's say
you're now going to know that and so I
was able to take my experience with them
on the run and
a year later I started a web series with
my co producers and we're basically our
own crew so I learned from my DP and the
gaffer's and the script d as a second ad
in everybody and I combined their skill
sets into what I was able to do even on
my tiny production for is going ready to
play you knocked it out of the ballpark
at your audition and next to the
thousands of submission dozens of
auditions fearful of callbacks that
other actors had for your role you got
us and there's something very special
about what you did at a height showed up
in that room about the level of play and
present that you brought to the game
that got you this role so don't stress
about it and don't lock yourself in and
don't shut down your sense of play to do
some kind of mechanized idea of what you
think is supposed to happen for your
performance because you're going to be
working with people who are fluid and
who are very present and it's just it's
play it's the best part of what we do so
coming ready to play coming ready to
experiment because you've got hired for
your singular essence it's what's so
important about you and be ready to
bring that to the table tip number five
it's going to be on your power so you've
wrapped your done with production and
everything is in post and you're so
excited for the festival circuit for
distribution for your premiere for
whatever is going to be happening you're
going to be in the limelight if you
allow yourself to be now is also a
really big time where self-sabotage
comes into play
and it might be a case of well my
co-stars are all really famous and I'm
not and maybe nobody wants to see me for
example you don't see someone who looks
like me in leading roles often I'm very
aware of that and it can be really
intimidating to be a person of different
size color or gender or ethnicity or
anything it can be difficult to be a
diverse performer and feel worthy and
feel like people want to see your
stories being told but the bottom line
is we are in perfect day and age for
more diverse stories to be told because
the culture is just starving for them so
even though that can be a really scary
thing when you are this one lone voice
in a sea of you know regular Hollywood
types allow that to be your fuel allow
what's theory to to be the thing that
has your stand up and raise your hand
and say I stand for people like me I
stand for our stories to be told it's so
empowering and if you bring that wealth
and tested and you bring that passion
and you bring that that truth inside you
to the forefront when you're working
with the publicist when you're working
in social media and you're promoting and
you're talking with your distributor
about how you can represent the film
that's going to be the lesson that the
viewers come away with more than
anything else so own who you are and own
your enthusiasm and your leadership